добрі оселю приїхав в президент України
Володимир Зеленський це його перший
візит в європейську столицю з початку
повномасштабної війни в Україні та
вперше з того моменту як Україна стала
країною кандидатом на вступ у
Європейський союз і тут Брюсселі його
зустрічали всі лідери інститутів
Європейського Союзу і
президентка єврокомісії урсула фон
дерляйн і
президент ради ЄС шарм-ель-шейх і спікер
Європейського парламенту Роберта мицола
не може розповісти що звичайно Було дуже
важко дістатися Європейського парламенту
куди президент Зеленський поїхав після
того як приземлився його літак з Франції
до речі там його теж зустрічали і
зустрічали з оркестром та з червоним
килимом а потім він поїхав в
європарламент в європарламент і
там було дуже багато людей багато
публіки журналістів всі чекали на нього
і був великий натовп
позабудівлею та
безпосередньо на шляху до зали
Європейського парламенту де він мав
виступати
його зустріли і
він відбулася зустріч Зеленського з
мецолею в її кабінеті де вона я показала
йому малюнки українських дітей які
висять в неї у рамочці тому що коли вона
відвідувала Україну вперше їй подарували
ці малюнки на жаль тема цих малюнків не
тільки Україна але війна вона також
показала зеленському фото його жінки
першої леді України Олени зеленської в
європарламенті коли вона виступала тут
минулого року і фото своїх дітей
звичайно Тому що вона хотіла показати
президентові що це його дім вона так і
сказала президенти Зеленський для нас
велика
честь те що ви приїхали до нас в
Брюссель Це ваш дім і те що ви робите
сьогодні в Україні це для нас
Брюсселі
найкращий проект над яким ми можемо
взагалі працювати
[музика]
гімн України в європарламенті Звучав
сьогодні двічі він Звучав під прапорами
України та ЄС Де стояли мицоли та
Зеленський для фото та у самому залі
куди президент Пішов під вітальні вигуки
всіх присутніх і як я вже казала люди
стояли в коридорах на сходах весь
простір був заповнений людьми
євродепутати серед яких багато хто був у
блакитному та жовтому тобто
жовто-блакитному у різних відтінках
в деяких були стрічки
кольорів українського прапора навіть я
бачила людей у вишиванках відчувалася
якась атмосфера свята тобто
дуже піднесений настрій всі чекали
аплодували стоячи і такого Ну я ще не
бачила в своєму житті тому що
український лідер
прибув в Брюссель але здається що
Україна вже
має свою перемогу вже перемогла у війні
виступ мецоли та виступ Зеленського
супроводжувалася великою кількістю
аплодисментів овацій і
овації стоячи і навіть у залі для преси
журналісти не всі звичайно але деякі
Після промови Зеленського також
аплодували ми
захищаємось від найбільш анти
європейської сили сучасного світу ми
захищаємось ми Українці на полі бою
разом з вами
і ми мусимо захиститись і це Важливо не
лише для держав Європи не лише для
спільнот Європи Ким би ми не були ми
завжди боремося проти зневаги де б ми не
жили ми завжди робимо ставку на
добросовісність про що б ми з вами не
мріяли для своїх дітей для своїх онуків
безумовно тлом для цих наших мрій є мир
мир та безпека ми наближаємось до
Євросоюзу Україна буде членом Євросоюзу
Україна Що Україна що перемагає членом
Євросоюзу Євросоюзу що перемагає
Роберта Мацола у своїй промові сказала
що
проукраїнських героїв про захисників
Маріуполя
острова зміїни та
тих хто звільняв багато міст та селищ в
Україні будуть розповідати ще багато
поколінь не тільки в Україні але в усій
Європі Вона
назвала українців та інших європейців
братами та сестрами та пообіцяла що в
європарламенті буде політична воля для
того щоб прискорити процес вступу
України до Європейського Союзу та надати
Україні ту зброю про яку вона просить